wir kommen jetzt in einem anderen zimmer
zu einer wirklichen schock umfrage die
schockiert das muss man ganz klar sagen
ganz deutschland denn nur noch rund
jeder zehnte fühlt sich in seinem alltag
frei und findet er kann sein leben so
führen wie er oder sie es gerne möchte
er das hat eine umfrage des instituts
european council on foreign relations
ergeben und das schlimmste ist damit ist
deutschland auf dem letzten platz der
befragten eu länder das sind dramatische
zahlen ja in keinem anderen eu-land der
europäischen land fühlen sich die
menschen durch die korona regeln
beschränkung der regierung so unfrei wie
in deutschland das sagt diese umfrage
das ist eine ziemliche quittung für die
korona politik der vergangenen
anderthalb jahre hier in deutschland und
ja wir zeigen ihnen das ganze mal haben
diese umfrage noch mal für sie
aufgearbeitet liegt aktuell nicht vor
aber dass das ergebnis patricia das was
du gerade gesagt hast also ausgerechnet
hier bei uns in deutschland da ja findet
man dass die korona regeln den eigenen
alltag ganz besonders beschränken die
persönliche freiheit so ganz besonders
einschränken wir schauen einmal ganz
genau rein in diese umfrage und diese
ergebnisse die derzeit ganz deutschland
schocken
[Musik]
weil
werde ich mich ob werden zu gehen wieder
abnehmen
moment
noch ein bisschen eingeschränkt
oder
außenansicht noch mal noch ein bisschen
zu einem schönen spiel der münchner
vorbei ich die masken mit der halle wäre
nicht frei ist es nicht eher so fühlen
sie sich also so fühlen sich unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer derzeit mit
den corona maßnahmen man muss das noch
mal betonen deutschland europaweit
absolutes schlusslicht wenn es um die
bewertung der eigenen freiheiten geht
bei uns im studio ist nina schenk unsere
erfolgs autorin und auch bei uns in der
wirtschaftsredaktion und sie ist das
weiß ich nehme eine große verfechterin
der freiheit das ist etwas was sie
besonders am herzen liegt was sagst du
jetzt zu diesen ergebnissen 49 prozent
fühlen sich nicht frei ich bin total
erleichtert ich habe wirklich mit den
deutschen auch starke habe so das ist
verstehst alleine daher ich dachte ich
stehe alleine da ich stand auch lange
alleine da hinein nicht ganz alleine
aber ich war erschrocken es gab nämlich
eine studie die wird immer erhoben auch
für die nations wie glücklich die länder
sind und im jahr 2020 ist deutschland
acht plätze nach vorne also in panama
sind wir das glücks land geworden ich
finde das nicht einig sind haben sie
gute nachricht moment da sind wir acht
plätze nach vorne auf platz sieben
gegangen im vergleich und da war es bei
mir damals so wir sind glücklicher
geworden während der pandemie wirklich
ist war für mich furchtbar zu lesen weil
ich dann gedacht habe wir wissen ja
anscheinend unsere persönliche freiheit
gar nicht mehr zu schätzen wenn wir auf
platz sieben nach vorne gehen also
glücklich und unfrei wir wollen einmal
warfen kubicki in unserer galerie holen
glücklich aber unfrei dass also das
resümee was viele deutschen für sich in
dieser corona krise ziehen herr kubicki
wie bewerten sie diese uns umfrage 49
sind europäisches schlusslicht fühlen
sich unfrei
ja diese studie bestätigt ja das was vor
14 tagen schon der freiheit monitor
dokumentiert hat die überwiegende
mehrzahl der deutschen fühlt sich und es
hat sehr viel damit zu tun dass in der
korona pandemie der alge
bewegungsspielraum eingeschränkt worden
ist man weiß gar nicht ganz genau weil
er debatte beispielsweise jetzt wo geh
oder 3g woran man noch teilnehmen kann
auf man im urlaub reisen kann die mal
wieder zurückkommt wie die kinder in der
schule versorgt werden all dies führt
dazu dass das persönliche
freiheitsgefühl zurecht abnimmt
gleichzeitig führen die menschen sie
selbstverständlich auch in der korona
pandemie glücklich weil sie wesentlich
tagsüber züge wieder in ihrem sozialen
umfeld in ihrer familie gefunden haben
das erleben wir ja in der vergangenheit
schon seit längerem dass es wieder ein
bezug gibt auch die eigene familie auf
den eigenen kleinen sozialen
umkreis das ist also kein widerspruch
sondern bedient sich geradezu denn wenn
man im öffentlichen leben nicht mehr
vernünftig teilnehmen kann da reduziert
weil sich aufs private jetzt verstehe
ich einst nicht an den ergebnissen der
studie vielleicht können sie mir helfen
herr kubicki denn sie haben ja mit der
fdp unter anderem immer wieder in den
vergangenen monaten diese
freiheitseinschränkung scharf kritisiert
die krone regeln scharf kritisiert jetzt
hat es ja demzufolge aber so sein müssen
die laufen ja in massen zur fdp über die
wählen sie in massen oder laufen
zumindest in den umfragen zu ihnen war
aber nicht so die haben in großen teilen
weiterhin den corona kurs der
bundesregierung unterstützt können sie
es erklären
ja so eine umfrage daten sie ich das
nicht ich sehe nur teil nicht erst jetzt
hier die eu bei der crawler maßnahmen
jetzt massiv unterstützt worden es ist
ja nicht nur armee das schätzt der
schlechten umfragedaten bekommt sondern
auch die union insgesamt als partei ich
glaube aber dass in einer phase der
unsicherheit menschen die sicherheit
vermitteln und habe ich von der frage ob
der shooter oder nicht also angela
merkel als kanzlerin oder auch jetzt
olaf scholz als sehr trockener kandidat
der spd dass die den menschen aufgrund
ihrer persönlichkeitsstruktur sicherheit
vermitteln oder vorgaukeln man sich
deshalb an diesen menschen auch
orientiert das erklärt für mich momentan
das wiederaufleben der sozialdemokraten
unter olaf scholz herr kubicki fühlen
sie sich denn frei oder schließen sie 10
49 prozent an ja ich fühle mich nicht
freie obwohl ich mir dafür kämpfe
möglichst viel freiheiten zu erlangen
ich bin gerade in hamburg und habe
wieder eine merkwürdige feststellung
machen müssen hier in hamburg darf man
bei den zweijährigen
private feierlichkeiten durchführen ohne
menschen beginnt begrenzung was ja
logisch ist bei genießen und gebens
finden und keiner kann ihn umgebenden
andererseits werden sie eine
familienfeier machen und tanzen vor
seiner hochzeit feiern dann wird das 150
personen begrenzt und sie müssen beim
tanzen maske tragen was ist das für ein
unsinn wenn ich nur in mesum geimpfte
bei mir auf der feier habe dass die
masken tragen da sind dann sie tanzen
wollen ich glaube eine hochzeit und das
ist brauchbar sich gar nicht vorstellen
welche freiheit fehlt ihnen aktuell noch
am allermeisten welche wünschen sie sich
am allermeisten zurück das tanzen die
einschränkungen beim küssen die sie
gerade genannt haben fast was fehlt dem
herrn kubicki am allermeisten und
letzteres würde meine frau sozusagen auf
finden dass ihr wir küssen uns auch ohne
maske keine sorge aber was mir am
meisten fehlt ist die disposition bei
meinem leben dass ich entscheiden kann
ich ein restaurant zu gehen ohne dass
ich da zurückgewiesen werden kann dass
sich entscheiden kann kino zu gehen und
ohne das zurückgewiesen werden kann also
die rückkehr meiner möglichkeiten am
normalen leben wider teilzunehmen die
normalität so schnell wie möglich
herzustellen das ist das was ich
wirklich will und ich vermisse wie
gesagt ist dispositions feiert aber
neuesten herr kubicki ich habe auch eine
frage ich bin letzte woche ins
restaurant gegangen musste dann mein
impfausweis vorzeigen sonst wenn ich
reinkomme oder ein test ich habe mich
immer gefragt ob das wirklich notwendig
ist dass wir jetzt diese ausweise immer
vorzeigen müssen bei letztes jahr hatten
wir keine impfquote und da musste man
das nicht machen im test oder ein
impfausweis mitnehmen warum ist das
jetzt so ich habe mich schon gefühlt ich
halte diesen impfausweis er hat sich
angefühlt wie ein privileg gut fand ich
es aber nicht
ja die frage müssen sie mir nicht schwer
sondern diejenigen die das eingeführt
haben ich finds auch ganz toll dass die
bundeskanzler jetzt auf die idee kommt
nur noch 3g in züge zu lassen als wir
noch gar nicht geimpfte aber reichte die
maske und jetzt wo wir was 70 prozent
der menschen geimpft sollen wir mit
einer dreijährigen verreisen können
ich glaube wir müssen den dänischen weg
gehen unsere dänischen nachbarn haben
die zehn september für den frieden
erklärte fällt alles weg da braucht sich
nicht mehr wehren impfpass impfnachweis
vorzulegen und die menschen können für
ihre eigene gesundheit selbstversorgung
und sorgen man kann sich zurückhaltend
man kann selbst auch noch privat maske
tragen ist nicht mehr vorgeschrieben wir
müssen wirklich zur normalität kommen
und dann glaube ich erreichen wir viel
mehr menschen als durch diese dauernde
angstmacherei und die dauernden druck
der erzeugt wird angst essen seele auf
wir müssen die menschen mut machen ihre
eigene gesundheit wieder in die eigenen
hände zu nehmen also fdp vize wolfgang
kubicki wünscht sich ein freedom day und
endlich mehr freiheit vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
wir haben auch die bild zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer und leser gefragt was
fehlt ihnen eigentlich am meisten was
wünschen sie sich jetzt in dieser
coronel krise die einfach nicht enden
wollte hier ist platz drei von lothar
mai er sagt ganz klar ich wünsche mir
die aufhebung der quarantänebestimmungen
für kinder das sagt also unser bild
de-leser lothar mai aus erfurt schließe
ich mich sofort an ein thema das wir
hier in diesen sendungen auch schon oft
besprochen haben ja lauter schmiedel hat
uns auch über bild.de eine mail
geschickt die ich ihnen vorlesen kann
hier von meinem computer also mein
wunsch ist es dass meine liebe kranke
frau endlich wieder mit mir zusammen
einkaufen gehen kann schreibt er also
also das ist die freiheit
verständlicherweise die ihm aktuell
fehlt ja und ihnen fehlen natürlich noch
viel mehr freiheiten hier sehen wir noch
mal den beitrag von ote ich wünsche mir
die aufhebung der quarantäne für kinder
aber andere wünschen sich auch einfach
mal wieder ohne maske in bars zu gehen
und cocktails zu schlürfen auch völlig
verständlich das wünscht sich zum
beispiel wolfgang jentsch aus frankfurt
und ich wünsche mir ich wünsche mir dass
meine tochter dein sohn im klassenzimmer
nicht mehr mit maske sitzen müssen das
ist mein persönlicher wunsch und der
cocktail wunsch von herrn kentsch der
wird hoffentlich auch wieder bald in
erfüllung gehen wobei beim cocktail
trinken maske tragen ich glaube dass das
haben die wenigsten eingelöst in dieser
zeit aber der wunsch ist total
nachvollziehbar klare freisleben ohne
maske überall rein ja absolut
nachvollziehbare wunsch absolut uns ist
weiterhin der schinken studierenden am
meisten
weil ich keine kinder habe bin ich
ehrlich gesagt komplett bei dir ich
wünsche mir dass kinder nicht mehr maske
in der schule sitzen müssen im
klassenzimmer und das ist eigentlich
mein größter wunsch ich bin da
eigentlich komplett bei der auch wenn
ich keine mutter bin ich finde das
fürchterlich und ich sehe dafür auch
kein
[Musik]